[Aplausos]
[Música]
ryanair es una de las empresas más
innovadoras del mundo y a la vez una de
las más odiadas todos hemos oído hablar
del test lie del hiper loop pero
necesitaremos esperar unos cuantos años
para ver en qué medida estas empresas
cambiarán nuestra vida
ryanair ya ha supuesto una auténtica
revolución y no solo en europa sino en
todo el mundo
sin embargo es difícil encontrar a
alguien que no procese un odio visceral
contra ryanair esto se debe en parte a
los esfuerzos de su ceo michael o'leary
pocas personas han trabajado tan duro
para ganarse la animadversión de propios
y extraños con declaraciones como esta
necesitamos que haya menos gente yendo a
los baños de los aviones
como lo evitaremos les cobraremos por
ello o esta otra nadie quiere sentarse
al lado de un córdoba francamente nos ha
sorprendido ver la cantidad de pasajeros
que no sólo quieren poner un impuesto
especial a los gordos pero incluso
quieren torturarles pero hay una razón
aún más importante por la que tanta
gente odia a ryanair os voy a dar un
ejemplo si lleváis tiempo suscritos a
visual político ya sabéis que yo soy
español pero vivo en república checa
eso significa que muchas veces vuelo a
madrid para ver a mis amigos ya mi
familia durante años los vuelos praga
madrid costaban alrededor de
200 250 euros pero este año ryanair ha
llegado a la ciudad y ha ofrecido vuelos
para madrid por precios tan bajos como
75 euros que han hecho las demás
aerolíneas que volaban hacia españa pues
no les ha quedado otro remedio que bajar
sus precios era eso o desaparecer
y lo mismo ha ocurrido en toda europa
allí donde ryanair ofrece sus vuelos a
precios de saldo el resto de compañías
tienen que bajar sus tarifas también eso
significa menos beneficios o incluso la
bancarrota para que os hagáis una idea
en el año 2000 british airways llegó a
transportar a más de 46 millones de
pasajeros ocho años más tarde a duras
penas llegaban a los 33 millones y
lógicamente esas grandes aerolíneas como
lufthansa british airways o iberia se
han gastado auténticas fortunas en
comprar publicidad en los medios de
comunicación
con eso se ganaban el cariño de los
periodistas y una campaña de
desprestigio hacia ryanair que apenas
compra espacios publicitarios sin
embargo pese a la mala prensa pocas
empresas han cambiado tanto una
industria entera como ryanair y no
hablamos sólo de europa la influencia de
ryanair se nota prácticamente en todo el
mundo - en una parte latinoamérica así
que la primera pregunta que nos tenemos
que hacer es cómo ha cambiado el mundo
ryanair porque decimos que latinoamérica
necesita una empresa como esta y lo que
es más importante por que ryanair es
capaz de ofrecer precios tan bajos hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
porque ryanair es tan barato en los años
80 un vuelo madrid-londres valía unas
100 mil pesetas que es el equivalente a
600 euros
en aquella época eso era el sueldo de un
mes para un español medio todo el mundo
daba por sentado que volar era un lujo
los aviones son caros así que no hay
nada que hacer punto sin embargo mis
queridos amigos de visual político las
razones por las cuales los vuelos eran
tan caros tenían poco que ver con la
tecnología y mucho que ver con la
política tal cual como lo es
veréis por aquellos años las rutas
aéreas dependían de acuerdos entre
gobiernos por ejemplo el gobierno
francés y el gobierno estadounidense
tenían un acuerdo según el cual
solamente las aerolíneas francesas o las
estadounidenses podían volar entre parís
y nueva york y lo mismo ocurría con el
resto de países esto significa que las
aerolíneas tenían un monopolio sobre los
vuelos que operaban así que para que
iban a competir en ofrecer precios bajos
si podían facturar auténticas fortunas
cobrando seiscientos euros por un vuelo
eso explica que por aquel entonces solo
los británicos y los irlandeses podían
disfrutar de esos vuelos baratos que
ofrecía ryanair sin embargo en abril de
1997 las cosas cambiaron para siempre
a partir de este mes cualquier aerolínea
técnicamente cualificada en europa podrá
ofrecer servicios en todos los países de
repente todas las aerolíneas europeas
podían competir entre ellas pero como no
estaban acostumbradas a tener que
ofrecer mejores servicios se dedicaron a
invertir en publicidad y lujos mejores
comidas asientos más cómodos o incluso
regalos corporativos para los pasajeros
ryanair por su parte sacó nuevos vuelos
pero con una estrategia totalmente
distinta
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y las otras aerolíneas se preguntan cómo
pueden subir sus tarifas nosotros nos
preguntamos cómo podíamos eliminarlas
decir algo así en el año 1997 era una
auténtica locura por supuesto que ya
existían otras compañías de bajo coste
pero ryanair quería ir mucho más allá y
por eso empezaron a buscar todo tipo de
estrategias para reducir sus costes al
mínimo
[Música]
por ejemplo el coste de aterrizar o
despegar un avión depende en buena
medida de las tasas que cobran los
aeropuertos para que os hagáis una idea
aterrizar en el aeropuerto de bruselas
es muy caro sin embargo 60 kilómetros al
sur de bruselas hay otro aeropuerto el
de charleroi con unas tarifas mucho más
baratas sólo por el hecho de usar este
aeropuerto
ryanair se ahorra una auténtica fortuna
otra medida de ahorro es utilizar el
mismo modelo de avión para todas las
rutas el boeing-737
[Música]
y otras compañías como lufthansa
trabajan con hasta 14 tipos de avión
distintos
eso significa que necesitan 14 técnicos
de mantenimiento especializados en cada
uno de los modelos ryanair solo necesita
unos pocos técnicos para preparar toda
su flota y por eso mientras lufthansa
necesita varias horas de descanso entre
un vuelo y el siguiente
ryanair puede hacer sus inspecciones de
mantenimiento en la mitad de tiempo y
por supuesto a todo esto hay que sumarle
todos los extras que se ahorran durante
los vuelos quieres comida en el avión la
tienes que pagar aparte quieres llevar
varias maletas las tienes que pagar
aparte quieres elegir tu asiento lo
tienes que pagar aparte cada año ryanair
descubre nuevos detalles con los que
ahorrar costes por ejemplo desde hace
unos años la parte trasera de los
asientos se alquila como espacio
publicitario pero sin duda alguna el
punto de inflexión llegó en el año 2000
es en ese momento cuando michael o'leary
la decisión crucial que cambiaría la
industria de la aviación para siempre
a las agencias de viajes habría que
agarrar a esos mamés y dispararles que
han hecho por los pasajeros durante
tantos años efectivamente en el año 2000
ryanair fue la primera empresa en crear
una página web desde la que se podían
comprar los billetes hasta entonces era
prácticamente imposible comprar un
billete de avión a no ser que vivieras
cerca del aeropuerto así que los agentes
de viajes eran un intermediario
imprescindible y lógicamente cobraban
unas comisiones nacho vidal ianas de
hasta el 30% pero de repente con ryanair
los pasajeros podían entrar en una
página web buscar el vuelo más barato y
comprarlo todo esto que ahora nos parece
completamente normal fue una auténtica
revolución y la bancarrota de muchas
agencias de viajes que ya no tenían nada
que hacer con sus clientes para que os
hagáis una idea en el año 2010 ryanair
era capaz de ofrecer billetes por una
media de 32 euros fijaos en la
diferencia con los 6
euros de los que hablábamos antes y os
preguntaréis por qué os decimos que los
vuelos baratos son tan revolucionarios
pensando bien desde que ryanair se
expandía por europa el número de
pasajeros se ha multiplicado por tres en
poco más de diez años prestaba atención
a la gráfica porque no sólo hablamos de
turistas
gracias a tener vuelos baratos los
programas de intercambio de estudiantes
se han multiplicado por cinco desde el
año 2007 entre hecho seguro que los que
veáis este vídeo desde españa habréis
estudiado con alguna beca erasmus en
algún momento de vuestra carrera lo
mismo ocurre con la movilidad laboral
que se ha triplicado en la última década
gracias a los vuelos baratos
yo puedo visitar a mis amigos en
valladolid en españa' tantas veces como
quiera y todo eso por no hablar de la
cantidad de pequeños negocios que han
sido posibles gracias a que ahora hasta
el autónomo más humilde puede buscar
clientes en otros países
esperad un momento porque todavía hay un
detalle que tenemos que mirar en la
gráfica si os fijáis los vuelos en
europa han crecido una barbaridad sin
embargo en latinoamérica no ocurre lo
mismo que está pasando en el resto del
mundo y qué está pasando en
latinoamérica podemos hablar de un
efecto ryan era a nivel mundial o es
algo endémico de europa vamos a verlo
el efecto ryanair ya sé lo que estáis
pensando que ryanair solamente opera en
europa como es posible que hayan tenido
semejante influencia en todo el mundo
pues juzgar por vosotros mismos
en asia era una aerolínea del gobierno
de malasia a principios de los años 2000
estaba a punto de arruinarse pero en el
año 2001 el empresario malayo tony
fernández la compró a precio de saldo y
decidió imitar este efecto ryanair que
ya estaba empezando a funcionar en
europa bajo el eslogan de ahora todo el
mundo podrá volar empezó a ofrecer los
primeros vuelos 'low cost' en asia
de repente volar desde kuala lumpur
hasta macao costaba menos de 90 dólares
[Aplausos]
y al igual que ocurrió en europa en asia
han surgido montones de aerolíneas de
bajo coste desde lionel en indonesia
hasta cebu pacific en filipinas para que
os hagáis una idea en un país tan pobre
y a la vez tan grande como la india se
han triplicado el número de vuelos
comerciales en solamente 10 años
[Música]
sin embargo latinoamérica es una
historia totalmente distinta por ejemplo
un vuelo barato entre bogotá y ciudad de
méjico nos costaría alrededor de 460
dólares
y compararlo con los 86 dólares que
pagaríamos para viajar desde kuala
lumpur hasta taipei y por si lo queréis
comprobar las distancias son
prácticamente las mismas un vuelo de
tres horas entre lima y la paz nos sale
por casi 600 dólares en otras palabras
en latinoamérica todavía hace falta
ahorrar el sueldo de un mes para poder
hacer un viaje en avión y os
preguntaréis por qué es tan caro volar
en latinoamérica porque no hay ninguna
empresa estilo ryanair que haya
revolucionado los viajes en avión
[Música]
la respuesta nuevamente está en la
política y es que mis queridos amigos de
visual political y cómo funciona las
legislaciones en los distintos gobiernos
latinoamericanos es prácticamente
imposible que surge un ryanair para que
os hagáis una idea si una aerolínea
quisiera operar en brasil necesitaría
que al menos el 20% de la propiedad
estuviera en manos de una compañía
brasileña y ojo porque hasta hace dos
años el porcentaje era aún más alto ahí
tenemos el caso de avianca una aerolínea
colombiana que quería abrir mercados en
el país de la samba y el carnaval el
gobierno les obligó a crear una empresa
nueva
avianca brasil con capital brasileños
y por eso a bianca y avianca brasil son
dos empresas totalmente distintas aunque
pertenezcan al mismo grupo pero brasil
no es el único país que quiere proteger
sus aerolíneas hasta el año 2016 los
argentinos que quisieran volar tenían
que elegir entre dos aerolíneas o bien
argentina la cta que era privada o bien
aerolíneas argentinas que pertenecía al
gobierno
[Música]
durante décadas la administración de
kirchner se encargó de que ninguna
aerolínea extranjera pudiera competir
con sus niñas bonitas y lo mismo ocurre
con los aeropuertos recordáis lo que os
decía que ryanair podía recortar gastos
gracias a despegar en aeropuertos
baratos eso es posible porque en europa
uno de cada cuatro aeropuertos está
gestionado por consorcios entre los
distintos gobiernos y empresas privadas
gracias a esto los aeropuertos tienen
que competir entre ellos por ofrecer
tasas más baratas y mejores servicios no
es casualidad que estos aeropuertos
público privados gestionen la mitad del
tráfico aéreo europeo pues bien en
latinoamérica casi todos los aeropuertos
están gestionados íntegramente por
gobiernos nacionales si no hay
competencia tampoco va a haber interés
por reducir las tasas aeroportuarias en
otras palabras que parece muy complicado
que se pueda replicar este efecto
ryanair en esta región
y cuáles son las consecuencias de todo
esto pues que aunque muchos países de
latinoamérica hayan crecido
económicamente y cada vez más gente está
saliendo de la pobreza volar sigue
siendo un privilegio para las clases
altas
[Música]
así que la pregunta es creéis que habría
una mayor integración entre los países
latinoamericanos si se liberalizará el
espacio aéreo os gustaría tener un
ryanair en vuestro país
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto si queréis
descubrir como irlanda salió de la
pobreza y se convirtió en la potencia
que es hoy en día podéis hacer clic en
este otro vídeo y como siempre no
olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribiros a este
canal para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os han
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]